un flojo comienzo de campaña había
dejado a muchos cuestionando su
compromiso de volver a presentarse
Donald Trump se apresuró a dejar eso de
lado durante sus dos primeros mítines
decían no está haciendo campaña esto es
como hace un mes cuando lo anuncié bueno
dije ya sabes tengo dos años Ahora estoy
más enfadado y más comprometido que
nunca unos pocos cientos de acérrimos
partidarios de Trump se presentaron en
Carolina del Sur el expresidente cuenta
con ellos para impulsar su tercera
candidatura a la casa blanca estos
votantes ven la presidencia de biden
como algo pasajero
hay muchos demócratas que ven Lo que
pasa en Washington o en todo el país y
se dan cuenta de que quizá no era tan
malo en su papel de hombre corriente
Trump también pasó por un local de
comida rápida a tomar un helado su
mensaje sigue siendo soy uno de vosotros
solo hay un presidente que ha desafiado
a todo el establecimiento de Washington
y con su voto el año que viene lo
volveremos a hacer
Trump es el único republicano que ha
anunciado su candidatura hasta ahora
pero no será el último se dice que el
Gobernador de Florida ronde santis la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur Nicky
Haley el ex vicepresidente Mike pence
están supesando sus candidaturas para
diferenciarse Trump ha vuelto a viejos
temas favoritos como la migración están
enviando a personas que son asesinas
asesinas están enviando violadores están
enviando francamente terroristas o
terroristas que vienen por su cuenta y
no podemos permitir que esto suceda nada
se deja al azar ni siquiera la música
Dios bendiga a Estados Unidos pero los
mayores obstáculos para hacerse con la
nominación del partido republicano
pueden ser sus crecientes problemas
legales en particular sobre su papel en
la insurrección de 2021 y sus intentos
de anular su derrota electoral de 20